[Music]
George himself he and Matt Damon were in
Venice for their film suburbicon Matt
actually opened the festival with the
premiere of as the other movie
downsizing and that caused Clooney and
Carly Steele to give the Damon's their
own fashion upgrade Matt owned Venice
from the downsizing premiere to the red
carpet for his suburbicon but in the
satirical thriller Matt rocks this look
playing a dark family man as he and
director George depict the American
dream as a nightmare its Clooney's third
time directing his buddy well it's not
the first time I've worked with the
wonderful and talented and brilliant
George Clooney he does things that other
directors just can't do he pays me in
cash daily you just don't see other
people doing that at this level we did
not I'm gonna say that right now
yeah great that's the greatest I've ever
worked for there we go how this works
out well in fact I don't know a better
actor I've ever seen in my life
well there's bromance has certainly
blossomed since they first worked
together in Ocean's eleven it's still
nice to be in the business to be here 16
years later and still be working and
still be working on stuff that we love
that's really that's that's a real
blessed life actually
to share that together not really I was
more talking about myself yes
[Music]
Oh